Academy president Cheryl Boone Isaacs
and Chris Pine
welcome what an exciting morning Thank
You Alfonso and JJ for kicking it all
off Chris let's continue for performance
by an actor in a supporting role the
nominees are
Robert Duvall in the judge Ethan Hawke
and boyhood Edward Norton in Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance
Mark Ruffalo in Foxcatcher and JK
Simmons in whiplash
for performance by an actress in a
supporting role the nominees are
Patricia Arquette in boyhood Laura Dern
and wild Keira Knightley in the
imitation game Emma Stone in Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance and
Meryl Streep in into the woods for
achievement in makeup and hairstyling
the nominees are bill Corso and Denis
Liddy aired for Foxcatcher Francis
Hannon and Mark Cooley air for the grand
budapest hotel and elizabeth Yianni Gyo
Gyo and david white for guardians of the
galaxy for achievement and costume
design the nominees are
Molina Kenan arrow for the grand
Budapest hotel mark bridges for inherent
vice Colleen Atwood for into the woods
Anna B Shepherd and Jane Clive for
Maleficent and Jacqueline Duran for mr.
Turner for achievement in cinematography
the nominees are Emmanuel Lubezki for
Birdman or the unexpected virtue of
ignorance
Robert yeoman for the grand Budapest
hotel
Luke OSH y'all
and Rashard lankowski for EDA dick poop
dick Pope for mr. Turner and Roger
Deakins for unbroken for adapted
screenplay the nominees are Jason hall
for American sniper Graham Moore for the
imitation game Paul Thomas Anderson for
inherent vice Anthony McCartan for the
theory of everything and Damien Chazelle
for whiplash for original screenplay the
nominees are Alejandro G Inarritu and
Nicolas Jacobin Alexander Dean Elias jr.
and Armando bow for the Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance
Richard link later for boyhood Emacs
Frey and Dan Futterman for Foxcatcher
Wes Anderson and Hugo Guinness for the
grand Budapest hotel and Dan Gilroy for
Nightcrawler for Original Score the
nominees are Alexandre Desplat for the
grand Budapest hotel Alexandre Desplat
for the imitation game Hans Zimmer for
interstellar gary urine for mr. turner
and johann johansson for the theory of
everything in the Best Foreign Language
Film category the nominees are from
Poland EDA from Russia
Leviathan from Estonia tangerines from
Mauritania Timbuktu and from Argentina
while tales for achievement in directing
the nominees are Alejandro G in yachty 2
for Birdman or the unexpected virtue of
ignorance
richard linklater for boyhood Bennett
Miller for Foxcatcher Wes Anderson for
the grand budapest hotel and Morton
Tilden for the imitation game for
performance by an actress in a leading
role the nominees are Marion Cotillard
in two days one night Felicity Jones in
the theory of everything Julianne Moore
in still Alice Rosamund Pike and gone
girl and Reese Witherspoon in wild for
performance by an actor in a leading
role the nominees are
Steve Carell and Foxcatcher Bradley
Cooper an American sniper
Benedict Cumberbatch in the imitation
game Michael Keaton in Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance and Eddie
Redmayne in the theory of everything and
finally we are pleased to announce the
film's selected as the Best Picture
nominees they are american sniper clint
eastwood roberta Lorenz Andrew Lazar
Bradley Cooper and Peter Morgan
producers Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance Alejandro G in Y re
to John ledger and James W Scott
Chappell producers boyhood Richard
Linklater and Kathleen Sutherland
producers the grand budapest hotel wes
anderson Scott Rudin Stephen rails and
Jeremy Dawson producers the imitation
game Nora Grossman II do Ostrovsky and
Teddy Schwartzman producers Selma
Christina Coulson Oprah Winfrey DeeDee
Gardner and Jeremy kleiner
producers the theory of everything
Tim Bevan Eric Felner Lisa Bruce and
Anthony McCartin producers and whiplash
Jason Blum Helen Esther Brooke and David
Lancaster producers for the complete
list of all the nominations please visit
Oscar calm and join us Sunday night
February 22nd to celebrate these
incredibly incredible artists and films
at the Oscars with our host Neil Patrick
Harris see you at the Oscars
[Applause]
you